This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都是不安全的，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须这么做，听听怎么做吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。在2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支由网络侦探组成的团队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔（Scottsdale）警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。百分之二。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文数字2和百分号，在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
目标。他不会就这么逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的女朋友们。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, talk about the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are going to be talking about the psychology of revenge, what some of us might think of as an ugly feeling, but what is actually one of the most complex, layered human emotions that we can have. Some of my absolute favorite movies and books are written about this concept. Think like Kill Bill or Promising Young Women or Taken. And I find our human need for like an eye for an eye so interesting.
新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要探讨的是20多岁的心理学。今天，我们将探讨复仇心理学，复仇在某些人看来可能是一种丑陋的情绪，但它实际上是我们所能拥有的最复杂、最有层次的人类情感之一。我绝对最喜欢的一些电影和书籍就是围绕这个概念创作的。比如《杀死比尔》（Kill Bill）、《前程似锦的年轻女子》（Promising Young Woman）或《飓风营救》（Taken）。我发现人类对以牙还牙的需求是如此有趣。
It's one of those universal human impulses that we all get, whether or not we've acted on it, whether or not we've acknowledged it or not. You know, if only I could make my ex hurt the way that they hurt me, if only I could get back at that friend who betrayed me or that person who cut me off on the road, sometimes it almost feels satisfying to either enact revenge or to daydream about all the ways we could. Is that a good thing? Why do we feel such like a weird pleasure around hurting someone who hurt us. Here's the paradox as well. Revenge promises satisfaction, but more often than not, you might not know this, you probably do, but it actually leaves us feeling emptier than before.
这是我们所有人都会有的一种普遍的人类冲动，无论我们是否付诸行动，无论我们是否承认它。你知道，要是我能让我的前任像伤害我那样痛苦就好了，我要是能报复那个背叛我的朋友，或者那个在路上把我挤到的人就好了，有时，实施复仇或幻想各种复仇方式几乎让人感到满足。这真的是一件好事吗？为什么伤害那个伤害我们的人会让我们感到一种奇怪的快感？这里还有一个悖论。复仇承诺会带来满足感，但更多时候——你可能不知道，但你大概也猜得到——它实际上让我们比以前感到更加空虚。
It might feel good initially. Is it really worth the cost? And how do you navigate feeling such a messy, bitter feeling that maybe goes up against your more inherent desire to be a good person? why is the drive towards revenge so strong? When shall we act on it? When should we avoid it? These are all the kind of questions that we're going to be answering today's episode, as well as looking at some listener stories of people who have sought revenge and what the consequences were. There is so much pettiness, so much drama in this episode, so many good stories, and also so much psychology. It's almost unbelievable. So without further additional further attention, do let's get into the psychology of revenge. I feel like the idea of revenge is almost romantic at this
最初可能会感觉很好。这真的值得付出代价吗？当你内心这种混乱、苦涩的感觉，可能与你想要做一个好人的固有愿望相冲突时，你该如何应对？为什么复仇的驱动力如此强烈？我们什么时候该付诸行动？什么时候又该避免？这些都是我们将在今天的节目中解答的问题，同时我们还会回顾一些听众的故事，听听那些寻求复仇的人的经历以及随之而来的后果。这一期节目中包含了太多的琐碎和抓马，有太多精彩的故事，还有这么多的心理学知识。简直难以置信。那么，闲话少说，让我们切入复仇心理学。我觉得复仇的想法几乎可以说是浪漫的
point. It's like this driving force for so many dramatic moments. Some people would even call them poetic moments. So what exactly is it about revenge that makes it so powerful and so hard to resist? To understand revenge, we really have to start at the origin feeling, at what is going on before we even decide to get back at someone. When someone wrongs us, that's the beginning of this process, our brain obviously interprets it as a threat, not just to our safety, but also to more high-level cognitive values. So things like social status, it's a threat to social status, it's a threat to our sense of fairness, it's also a threat to our identity.
这一点。它是如此多戏剧性时刻的驱动力。有些人甚至称之为诗意的时刻。那么，复仇究竟有什么魔力，让它如此强大且让人难以抗拒？要理解复仇，我们真的必须从它的源头情绪开始，看看在我们决定报复某人之前到底发生了什么。当有人冤枉了我们，这是这个过程的开始，我们的大脑显然会将其解读为一种威胁，不仅是对我们安全的威胁，也是对更高层次的认知价值观的威胁。比如社会地位，这是对社会地位的威胁，是对我们公平感的威胁，也是对我们身份认同的威胁。
Now, when you have a healthy ego, there is this like invisible protective boundary or shield around you, it kind of represents like a limit of what you will and won't tolerate. And when someone oversteps that boundary when the shield is penetrated, that's when something pretty ancient in us is triggered. Now, some people's, you know, boundary shield is quite small and close to them, and some people's is quite wide. Regardless, it is actually completely subjective, but studies in the field of neuroscience have shown that when someone crosses that boundary, there is a the specific area in our brain called the dorsal striatum that immediately lights up. Interestingly, it's also the same area that lights up when we eat chocolate, when we win money,
现在，当你拥有一个健康的自我时，你的周围会有一道无形的保护边界或盾牌，它在某种程度上代表了你所能容忍和不能容忍的极限。而当有人越过了这条界限，当盾牌被穿透时，我们体内某个非常古老的东西就被触发了。现在，有些人的边界盾牌很小，离他们很近，而有些人的则很宽。无论如何，这其实完全是主观的，但神经科学领域的 الدراسات 研究表明，当有人跨越了这个边界时，我们大脑中一个被称为背侧纹状体（dorsal striatum）的特定区域会立即被点亮。有趣的是，当我们吃巧克力、赢得金钱时，这也是同一个被点亮的区域，
when we receive praise from somebody. In other words, the anticipation of revenge after someone has hurt us, harmed us, betrayed us, literally does feel initially quite pleasurable. This, from an evolutionary perspective, makes a lot of sense. We are wired to respond to injustice. If we think about early groups of humans, we pretty much relied on this elusive concept of fairness to survive. Being wronged, having your resources stolen, having your reputation undermined, having your partner taken, that could and would threaten your survival. And so revenge served as a signal to others that this kind of behavior was unacceptable. So, in a way, it actually worked to reinforce social rules and to deter people or others from
当我们受到别人的赞扬时。换句话说，在某人伤害了我们、伤害了我们、背叛了我们之后，对复仇的期待最初确实让人感觉相当愉悦。从演化的角度来看，这在很大程度上是说得通的。我们天生就会对不公做出反应。如果我们回想早期的人类群体，我们几乎完全依靠这种难以捉摸的公平概念来生存。受到委屈、资源被盗、声誉受损、伴侣被抢，这些都可能并且确实会威胁到你的生存。因此，复仇充当了一种信号，向其他人表明这种行为是不可接受的。所以，从某种程度上说，它实际上起到了强化社会规则、阻止他人或其他人进行
betrayal or from hurting people. Basically, it's like the classic idea of punishment, punishing the offender, teaching them a lesson, restoring harmony, and also signaling to the wider group that this is not okay, but also that you are not an easy target. And this kind of reputational enforcement that you are not somebody to be messed with was really adaptive in smaller communities where reputation affected access to mates to protection to resources. So long before laws or social contracts, this instinct was really, really helpful. It's actually what psychologists would call altruistic punishment. basically, yes, the outcome of revenge might not be necessarily positive for the other person,
背叛或伤害他人。基本上，这就像惩罚的经典理念，惩罚违法者，给她上一课，恢复和谐，并向更广泛的群体发出信号，表明这不是可以接受的，同时也表明你不是一个容易捏的软柿子。这种声誉上的强化——即你不是一个可以随便招惹的人——在小社区中非常具有适应性，因为在这些社区中，声誉会影响你获得伴侣、保护和资源的機會。因此，早在法律或社会契约出现之前，这种本能就非常非常有帮助。这其实就是心理学家所说的利他性惩罚。基本上，是的，复仇的结果对另一个人来说可能不一定是积极的，
but it also has a greater good in that it used to maintain group cooperation and it actually used to be good for social harmony, knowing that there was this balance between giving people respect and knowing that if you overstepped your boundary, you would also receive some kind of punishment that taught you not to do that. So it is a very, very old feeling. That's what we need to understand, especially if you feel a lot of guilt around wanting to enact revenge against someone. The question that we kind of get into is, why would it therefore still be useful in modern life? You know, when we have laws and law enforcement, when we have rules, when we have a legal system, why do we still feel the feeling if technically there are other systems that are meant to, you know,
但它也有一个更宏大的好处，那就是它曾经用于维持群体的合作，并且它实际上曾经有利于社会和谐，因为人们知道在给予他人尊重和知道如果你越界也会受到某种教训你不这样做的惩罚之间存在这种平衡。所以这是一种非常非常古老的感觉。这是我们需要理解的，特别是如果你对想要对某人实施复仇感到很多内疚的话。我们想要探讨的问题是，为什么它在现代生活中可能仍然有用呢？你知道，当我们拥有法律和执法部门，当我们拥有规则，当我们拥有法律体系时，为什么我们仍然会有这种感觉，如果从技术上讲，还有其他旨在——你知道的——
take care of that for us? the most obvious driver for revenge is this need for justice. And I know I just mentioned the legal system and law enforcement system. What if that system is broken? What if that system doesn't work in your interests? What if the thing that someone did wasn't necessarily illegal but still really hurt you deeply? Like what if it was someone who cheated or something really petty and small that you couldn't necessarily sue someone for, but which still really annoyed you and hurt you. I remember when my ex was secretly dating someone whilst we were having discussions of like, do we get back together or not?
为我们处理这些事情的系统存在？复仇最明显的驱动力是对正义的需求。我知道我刚刚提到了法律体系和执法系统。但如果这个系统崩溃了呢？如果这个系统不符合你的利益呢？如果某人做的事情不一定违法，但仍然深深地伤害了你呢？比如，如果有人作弊，或者发生了一些非常琐碎的小事，你没法因此起诉别人，但它确实让你非常恼火和受伤。我记得当我的前任在我们要不要复合的讨论期间，偷偷地和别人约会时。
And we were having all these talks about like, no, we definitely have a future together. Give me a second chance. And the whole time he was dating somebody else. And when I found out, I had never felt that surge of adrenaline before. that like this, to be honest, like desire to hurt him. And it honestly, like, it shocked me. Like, it made me see myself differently as an individual. This is like the classic they must pay kind of motive,
我们一直在讨论诸如“不，我们绝对有未来。给我第二次机会”之类的话。而他一直在和别人约会。当我发现的时候，我从未感受到过那种汹涌的肾上腺素。那种——说实话——想要伤害他的欲望。老实说，这让我感到震惊。这让我以不同的视角看待自己作为一个个体的存在。这就像是经典的“他们必须付出代价”的动机，
the belief that for fairness to be enacted, retribution is somewhat required. Revenge also allows us to reassert control. If we've been betrayed, humiliated, or made to feel powerless, us, like fantasizing about payback gives us a sense of agency, even if we don't do anything about it. There's this idea of like, yes, this person stepped all over me. Yes, this person hurt me. But I know I could get back at them if I wanted to. And therefore, I actually do have some level of control in this situation. So it kind of serves as this like emotional, moral, like psychological recalibration
这种信念认为，为了实现公平，报复在某种程度上是必要的。复仇也让我们能够重新夺回控制权。如果我们曾被背叛、羞辱或感到无力，幻想报复会给我们一种能动感，即使我们对此什么都不做。这就有一种想法，比如，是的，这个人把我踩在脚下。是的，这个人伤害了我。但我知道如果我想的话，我可以报复他们。因此，在这种情况下，我实际上拥有了一定程度的控制权。所以它在某种程度上充当了一种情感、道德、心理上的重新校准，
that stops us from being additionally hurt by this idea that we are powerless to what people do to us. Many people also believe that revenge actually helps people get closure. There's this perception that if you retaliate and make someone feel the way that they made you feel, that is when you can walk away. That is when the door is closed. Unsurprisingly, maybe surprisingly, research shows that revenge actually rarely provides closure. In fact, according to research published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, those who enact or engage in revenge actually tend to ruminate even more about the
阻止我们因为觉得自己在别人的行为面前无能为力而受到进一步的伤害。许多人还认为，复仇实际上有助于人们获得闭环（closure）。有一种看法是，如果你进行报复，让别人感受到他们让你感受到的痛苦，那才是你可以走开的时候。那才是大门关上的时候。不出所料，也许出乎意料的是，研究表明复仇实际上很少能提供闭环。事实上，根据发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》（Journal of Personality and Social Psychology）上的研究，那些实施或参与复仇的人实际上往往会更频繁地反刍（ruminate）
initial event, and they tend to actually feel that their negative emotions are kept alive. In comparison, people who resist revenge, even resist fantasizing about it, often recover faster emotionally from the event and from the person and the act that hurt them. Just something to keep in mind. The final driver towards revenge is just plain old impulsivity. It's like this knee-jerk reaction to feeling disarmed by someone else's action. We just have to lash out. That's a really crucial thing about revenge is that it often isn't planned.
最初发生的事件，并且他们往往会觉得自己的消极情绪被延续了下来。相比之下，那些抵制复仇、甚至抵制对此进行幻想的人，通常在情感上能更快地从事件以及伤害他们的那个人和行为中恢复过来。这一点值得记住。驱动复仇的最后一个因素就是纯粹的冲动。这就像是对被他人的行为解除武装所产生的一种膝跳反应。我们只是不得不进行反击。关于复仇，有一个非常关键的事实，那就是它通常不是经过策划的。
it is so primal and emotional that it's not strategic. You just want to hurt the other person, which is why it also tends to backfire or to not feel as good as we initially think it will. This might be like the angry text that you send that you really regret later on when you know you're meant to be the person who rises above things or like the public call out on your Instagram stories.
它是如此原始和情绪化，以至于根本谈不上战略性。你只是想伤害对方，这也是为什么它往往会适得其反，或者感觉不如我们最初想象的那样美好的原因。这可能就像是你发送的愤怒短信，事后当你意识到自己本来应该是一个能够超越这一切的人时，你会感到非常后悔，或者就像你在Instagram快拍上公开点名某人一样。
the heat of the moment reaction. You know, I, gosh, I like remember, I remember when a group of my closest friends all went on this overseas trip together when I was 19. And they didn't tell me and they kind of asked people, other people around us not to tell me either. And I ended up finding out from someone else, what was my reaction to that? It was to post this, like, really cringe Instagram story that was like, when someone shows you who you are, like, believe them.
那种当下冲动的反应。你知道，我，天哪，我记得——我记得当我19岁时，我的一群最要好的朋友一起去海外旅行。他们没有告诉我，而且他们还要求我们周围其他人也不要告诉我。结果我从别人那里知道了，我的反应是什么？我的反应是发布了一条非常尴尬的Instagram快拍，内容大概是“当一个人向你展示他是谁时，请相信他”。
Like, it's so awkward to think about right now, like, that I did that. And obviously, I ended up having a conversation with them, but, like, that was my first reaction. I feel so cringe. But in the moment, like, that was the only way, the impulsive way to restore balance in that situation. So this kind of impulsive revenge is driven by the limbic system. We speak about that a lot. It's this emotional center in your brain that has evolved to keep us alive in dangerous situations by being extremely reactive. Specifically, the amygdala is the key actor here. This is the part of your brain responsible for processing fear, anger, threats, humiliation, hurt. So when we do experience those things, the amygdala fires pretty instantly and it sends signals to our body that, you know, we need to be
现在想起来觉得太尴尬了——我居然干过那种事。当然，我最后还是和他们谈了谈，但那确实是我的第一反应。我觉得太尴尬了。但在当时，那是恢复那种情况下平衡的唯一方式，一种冲动的方式。这种冲动的复仇是由边缘系统（limbic system）驱动的。我们经常谈论这个。这是你大脑中的情感中心，它经过进化，通过保持极度反应，在危险情况下让我们保持生存。具体来说，杏仁核（amygdala）是这里的关键角色。这是你大脑中负责处理恐惧、愤怒、威胁、羞辱和伤害的部分。所以当我们真正经历这些事情时，杏仁核会几乎瞬间被激活，并向我们的身体发送信号，表明我们需要处于
on high alert, we need to be doing something, we need to be acting. And when it's an emotional situation where we can't necessarily fight back or run away or freeze, we lash out, I guess we fight back psychologically and emotionally and cognitively by trying in some way to be in control of the situation, even if it ends up being kind of ridiculous. This does not necessarily help us in the modern world. It has the potential to be very destructive. The tricky thing here is that,
高度戒备状态，我们需要做点什么，我们需要采取行动。当这是一个我们无法轻易反击、逃跑或呆立不动的感性情境时，我们就会发起反击，我想我们是在心理、情绪和认知上通过某种方式试图控制这一局势，即使最终结果可能会显得有些荒谬。这在现代社会并不一定能帮到我们。它有可能具有极大的破坏性。这里棘手的地方在于，
impulsive revenge is incredibly fleeting. Once the adrenaline fades, I promise you the satisfaction fades as well. What's left behind is often regret and shame. Studies, again, neuroscience studies have found that impulsive acts of aggression, they do produce short bursts of reward-related activity in our brains, followed by increases in negative self-referential processing. What does that mean? It's basically that like, oh crap, what have I done feeling?
冲动的复仇是极其短暂的。一旦肾上腺素消退，我向你保证，那种满足感也会消退。留下的往往是遗憾和羞耻。研究——同样是神经科学研究——发现，冲动的攻击行为确实会在我们的大脑中产生短暂的与奖励相关的活动爆发，随后是与自我相关的负面加工的增加。那是什么意思？基本上就是那种“糟了，我都干了些什么”的感觉。
They're like, what does this say about me feeling? I thought I was better than this feeling. And that feels awful. Of course, we also have planned revenge. This is the colder, more deliberate. kind that comes from higher up in the brain's hierarchy. It involves the prefrontal cortex. The prefrontal cortex and the amygdala are like the same but different. They are incredibly integral in how our brain operates, but the prefrontal cortex is all rational. It's long-term
它们就像是“这说明了我是一个什么样的人”的感觉。我以为我比这更好的感觉。那感觉太糟糕了。当然，我们也有周密策划的复仇。这是一种更冷酷、更蓄意的类型，来自大脑层级的更高处。它涉及前额叶皮层（prefrontal cortex）。前额叶皮层和杏仁核就像是既相同又不同。它们对我们大脑的运作至关重要，但前额叶皮层全是理性的。它是长期的
planning, it's impulse control. You would think that it would, and it is there to kind of mediate the amygdala. But when like our instinct for revenge gets shift. it into that space, suddenly as the injustice lingers and the hot-headedness and the rage goes down, there's like this new colder dimension to how we're thinking about hurting people. We're incredibly strategic. It's not chaotic. It's, yeah, it's planned. We're thinking it through sometimes for months on end and it can feel quite cathartic, considered, soothing. one story I heard from a listener was about how she got revenge on a boss who had harassed her by slowly keeping track of receipts and like basically indications that he was stealing money
规划，是冲动控制。你可能会认为它会——而且它的确存在于那里，起到调解杏仁核的作用。但当我们的复仇本能转移到那个空间时，突然间，随着不公正感的挥之不去、头脑发热和愤怒的消退，我们思考如何伤害他人时出现了一种新的、更冷酷的维度。我们变得极具策略性。这不是混乱的。是的，这是经过策划的。我们有时会连续几个月深思熟虑，这会让人感到相当宣泄、深思熟虑且具有抚慰作用。我从一个听众那里听到的一个故事是，她如何向一个曾骚扰过她的老板复仇：她慢慢地保留收据的记录，
from the restaurant that she was working at. So how she did this and I'm in a paraphrase what she said, but basically she was always offering to close the tills at the end of the night. And she would count all the money and she would count all the credit card transactions and whenever it was and keep like doubles of the receipts, take photos of the receipts, take photos of her count because she knew that the boss was taking like $300 to $400 to $400 off what she had put in and off her like calculations and claiming to his boss that like, you know, they'd made less for the day. And one day she was like, I waited for six months doing this slowly and slowly because he wouldn't do it
基本上就是他从她工作的餐厅里偷钱的证据。她是这么做的——我在这里意译一下她的话——基本上她总是主动提出在每天晚上打烊时清点收银机。她会清点所有的钱，清点所有的信用卡交易，无论什么时候，她都会保留收据的双份副本，拍下收据的照片，拍下她清点金额的照片，因为她知道老板会从她放入的金额和她计算的金额中扣除300到400美元，并向他的老板声称当天赚的钱变少了。有一天她说，我花了六个月时间慢慢地做这件事，因为他并不是每天都这么做。最后我去找了老板的老板，把他给开除了。你看，我不知道自己对这件事作何感想。我其实挺喜欢她这么干的。另一个更——我猜可以说是更阴险的故事来自一个听众，她的伴侣出轨了。她确实有证据。他并不知道她知道。但同样，她又和他多呆了三个月。她当时想：“我全情投入。我对他的感觉荡然无存，但我——就像是——让他确信我想结婚，他应该向我求婚，我们应该搬到一起住。”然后，在一个周末，他去进行了一场“男孩们的旅行”，而她趁着那个周末打包了半个房子，字面意义上在州外找到了一份工作，搬到了别的州，切断了所有联系，再也没有和他说过话。当时我想：“天哪，姑娘，这也太疯狂了吧。”你知道，你把他捧得高高的，让他觉得自己被深爱着。然后她就这样一刀两断，她说：“这就是他让我感受到的。”当时我想：“老实说，如果这能让你感觉好受点的话，权力属于你。”我猜。听起来他确实罪有应得。但如果你从未有过这种感觉，如果你从未能策划出这样一幕，有时这其实确实取决于我们的性格。对我来说，我形式上的复仇——复仇一直都是非常冲动的。但是，你知道，在那些
every day. And eventually I went to, like, my boss's boss and I got him fired. See, I don't know how I feel about that. I kind of love that for her. Another more, I guess sinister story was from a listener whose partner cheated. And she did have evidence. He didn't know that she knew. But again, she stayed with him for another three months. She was like, I just went all in. I felt nothing towards him, but I, like, convinced him that I wanted to get married, that he should like propose to me and we should move in together. And then one weekend he went on like a boy's trip and she packed up half the house left over that weekend and literally had gotten a job out of state, mood states,
每一天。最后我甚至找到了我老板的老板，把他给开除了。你看，我不知道自己对这件事该作何感想。我其实挺欣赏她这种做法的。另一个更阴暗一点的故事来自一位听众，她的伴侣出轨了。而且她确实掌握了证据。他并不知道她已经知道了。但话说回来，她又和他在一起呆了三个月。她当时的心态是，我决定全力以赴。我对他的感情荡然无存，但我让他确信我是想跟他结婚的，他应该向我求婚，我们应该搬到一起住。然后有那么个周末，他去参加单身汉派对之类的旅行，她就在那个周末收拾了半个家搬走了，甚至在别的州找了一份工作，搬去了外地，
no contact never spoke to him again. And I was like, this is girl, this is crazy. Like, you know, you built him up and you like made him feel so in love. And then she just like cut it off and she was like, that's what he made me feel. And I was like, honestly, power to you if it made you feel better. I guess. It kind of sounds like he deserves it. But if you've never felt this way, if you've never been able to plan this, sometimes it actually does come down to our personality. For me, like my form of revenge, revenge has always been very impulsive. But, you know, in the cases where
不一定是这些情况，而是人们在某些琐事上对某人采取极其强烈的报复手段的情况下，他们大脑的运作方式和性格中其实确实有一些与众不同的地方，社会学家、心理学家和神经神经科学家们一直试图弄清楚这一点。阿德莱德大学（University of Adelaide）有一位特定的社会心理学家叫伊恩·麦基（Ian McKee），他一直在研究这个，我想直到现在仍在继续。据他所说，在有计划的复仇方面更有复仇心的人，在两个特质上的得分往往更高。右翼威权主义（Right wing authoritarianism）。基本上，他们非常愿意服从权威人物，并且愿意以他们的名义采取攻击性行为。以及社会支配倾向（social dominance orientation）。他们希望
not necessarily these cases, but people where they go like really intense on someone over something petty, there is actually something probably different about how their brain operates and about their personality that sociologists and psychologists and neuroscientists have been trying to figure out. So there's one particular social psychologist called Ian McKee at the University of Adelaide who was looking into this, I think still at this very moment. And according to him, people who are more vengeful in the planned sense tend to actually score higher on two traits. Right wing authoritarianism. Basically, they're very willing to submit to authority figures and they're willing to act aggressively in their name. And social dominance orientation. They want
他们的群体处于等级制度的顶端。这些人受到权力、等级制度和地位维护的驱动。他们不想丢面子。他们更有可能寻求有计划的复仇。他的研究还表明，这些性格的人往往不那么宽容，不那么仁慈，更多地受权威和传统驱动，而不是同理心或理解。寻求复仇也有一个文化维度。米歇尔·盖尔芬德（Michelle Gelfand），这一领域的另一位心理学家，她和她的同事发现，触发我们复仇需求的因素其实在不同文化中有所不同。在美国、澳大利亚、英国和其他个人主义社会中，复仇通常由愤怒以及对个人权利的侵犯所推动，
their group to be at the top of the hierarchy. These individuals are motivated by power, by hierarchy, by the preservation of status. They don't want to lose face. They are much more likely to seek out planned revenge. His research also showed that these personalities tend to be less forgiving, less benevolent, and more driven by authority and tradition rather than empathy or understanding. There's also a cultural dimension to this as well, to seeking out revenge. Michelle Gelfand, another psychologist in this area, her and her colleagues found that what triggers our need for revenge actually differs across cultures. In the US, in Australia, in the UK and other individualistic societies, revenge is often fuelled by anger and the violation of personal rights,
对财产权利等事物的侵犯。比如，这是我的，它属于我，不要拿走，你不能拿，如果你敢试，我就会对你实施复仇。但在集体主义文化中，人们对这些东西并不那么大惊小怪。它更多的是关于，并且更多地被对职责和荣誉的侵犯以及针对社区的侵犯所触发。盖尔芬德还指出，在集体主义文化中，复仇实际上可能更具传染性，在这种文化中，当你伤害了某人的内群体（in-group）成员——比如家庭成员或亲密朋友——对这些人来说，这实际上比生活在个人主义社会的其他人更能让人感到是对自我的伤害。这不仅仅是我的痛苦，这就像是我们的痛苦。
the violation of things like property rights. Like, this is mine, it belongs to me, do not take it, you're not allowed it, and if you try, I'm a new and act. revenge on you. But in collectivist cultures, people aren't so fussed by that stuff. It's more about and more triggered by violations of duty and honor and violations against the community. Gelfin also noted that revenge can actually be more contagious in collectivist cultures as well, whereby when you harm a member of someone's in-group, so a family member or a close friend, that actually for those individuals feels more like harm to oneself than others who are living in individualistic societies. It's not just my pain, like it's our pain.
因此，在这些情况下，复仇不是关于个人气质。它更多的是关于文化和社会的归属感，以及维护集体主义社会的结构，而不是保护属于你自己的东西。我们要回到我之前提到过的那个观点，那就是在某种程度上，复仇实际上确实非常令人满意。那么代价呢？如果你坐在那里想，我正在权衡在这种情况下该怎么做。有人伤害了我。我想付诸行动。我们来谈谈你实际上应该做些什么。在短暂的休息之后，实际上，你应该做些什么？百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
So revenge in these situations isn't about personal temperament. It's more about cultural and social belonging and maintaining the fabric of the collectivist society rather than protecting what's yours. we're going to return to this idea I mentioned before, which is that on some level, revenge is actually really satisfying. What about the costs? If you are sitting there thinking, I'm kind of tossing up what I do in this situation. Someone has hurt me. I want to act on it. Let's talk about what you should actually do. Practically, what should you do after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
所以，在这些情况下，复仇并非关乎个人性格。它更多地关乎文化与社会归属感，以及维护集体主义社会的结构，而不是保护属于你的东西。我们要回到之前提到过的那个观点，那就是在某种程度上，复仇其实真的非常解气。那代价呢？如果你正坐在那儿琢磨，我有点在纠结在这种情况下我该怎么做。有人伤害了我。我想采取行动。让我们来谈谈你实际应该怎么做。在短暂的广告休息之后，从实际出发，你到底该做什么？2%。这是面对有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文数字2和百分号，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（double-tapped）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还把爱滋病摆在桌面上。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
我在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个活在世上的好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。和我一起，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《艰难抉择》并立即收听。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
在2023年前，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。“你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支由网络侦探组成的团队来破解这个案子。“我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。”
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court, hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋，还有迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔（Scottsdale）警方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县（Maricopa County）突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。复仇感觉太棒了。没有什么别的说法了。它激活了大脑的奖励中心。它给我们带来了控制感的飙升、快感的飙升。隐藏的代价当然是，这种感觉会消退，而且，我们策划和排练复仇的次数越多，我们就越把自己的情绪状态锚定在那个伤害过我们的人身上。我们的故事就越深地纠缠和交织在一起。我们越是把自己的平静建立在某种条件上，而那个条件就是他们的痛苦。这就是事情变得有点棘手的地方。爱荷华州立大学（Iowa State）在2022年进行了一项非常有趣的研究，
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Revenge feels amazing. There is no other way to say it. It activates the brain's reward centers. It gives us a search of control, a search of pleasure. The hidden cost is, of course, that fades, but also that the more we plot and rehearse revenge, the more we anchor our emotional state to the person who has hurt us. The more invested and intertwined our stories become. The more we make our peace conditional on something, and what What's conditional on is their pain. And this is where this can get a little bit tricky. There's a really interesting piece of research from Iowa State,
基本上观察了600名参与者。他们让这些人配对进行这个实验，研究人员要求他们写一篇非常基础的文章，并告诉他们这些文章将由他们的伙伴进行审查。但实际情况是，这项研究中的每个人都有同一个伙伴。那是一个研究助理。而那个研究助理兼研究团队给这其中的每个人——或者至少是其中一半的人，抱歉——非常糟糕的反馈。
conducted in 2022, which basically looked at 600 participants. They partnered them up for this experiment, and the researchers asked them to write just a really basic essay, and they were told that these essays would be reviewed by their partner. what was actually happening was that every single person in this study had the same partner. It was a research assistant. And that research assistant slash the research team gave every single one of these people, or at least half of these people, sorry, really bad feedback.
他们会说：“这真的很糟糕，这写得很烂，这太差劲了，你在这方面一点天赋也没有。”他们试图激怒参与者。所以所有的参与者都处于这种情境中。所有人都有不好的反馈。但随后参与者被分为三个不同的组，反刍组（rumination group）。这些参与者被要求击打沙袋，同时看着他们所谓伙伴的照片或概念。
They were like, this is really bad, this is poorly written, this is terrible, you don't have any talent for this. And they were trying to anger the participants. So all of the participants were in this condition. All of them had the bad feedback. But then participants were then split into three different groups, the rumination group. These participants were asked to hit a punching bag whilst looking at the photo idea of their supposed partner.
分心组（distraction group），他们被展示了一张运动员的照片，同时被要求考虑变得超级健康并击打沙袋。最后是控制组（control group），参与者在收到结果后被要求安静地坐一会儿。非常有趣的是，控制组的参与者——那些只是被要求“安静坐着，思考这个情况”的人——他们恢复得更快。与那些以某种方式宣泄情绪的参与者群体相比，他们表现出的愤怒和攻击性水平最低。
A distraction group where they were shown a picture of an athlete whilst being asked to think about becoming super fit and punching the bag. And finally, a control group where participants just, were asked to sit quietly for a little while after receiving their results. What's really interesting is that the participants in the control group, the ones who are just like, sit quietly, think about the situation, they got over it faster. They showed the lowest levels of anger and aggression compared to the groups of participants
单独地在痛苦中处理痛苦，这与我们的想法相反，也与我们的边缘系统告诉我们的相反，才是最好的选择。即使是最精心计算的复仇也是有心理代价的，并且确实会付出心理代价。它让你与伤害你的人纠缠在一起。它实际上延长了你对他们的情感依赖，这意味着他们仍然拥有权力。即使在他们缺席的情况下。
who vented their feelings in some way. Processing the pain in the pain, individually, counter to what we think and counter to what our Olympic system is going to tell us, is the best option. Even the most calculated revenge came at a psychological cost and comes at a psychological cost. It keeps you entangled with the person who hurt you. It actually prolongs your emotional dependence on them, meaning that they still have power. even in their absence.
这种你想要报复他们的想法仍然让他们得以存在于你的脑海中。有人向我形容它就像是情感流沙。你越是挣扎着想让别人感受到你的感受，你就越深地陷入你正试图逃离的痛苦之中。这呼应了许多情绪调节理论所告诉我们的。当我们感到愤怒时，我们就在巩固它的神经通路。每一次我们重播那个故事，
This idea that you want to get back at them still allows them to exist within your mind. Someone described it to me as like emotional quicksand. The harder you struggle to make someone else feel what you feel, the deeper you sink into the very pain that you are trying to escape. This echoes what a lot of emotional regulation theories will tell us. When we feel anger, we reinforce its neural pathways. Every time we replay the story,
我们脑海中每一次想要扯平的幻想，我们的大脑都在加强痛苦与复仇作为唯一解决方案之间的联系。关于复仇，奇怪的地方还在于：有时我们确实得到了我们想要的。你知道，道歉从未到来，所以我们确实扯平了。他们感受到了痛苦。理论上的平衡得到了恢复。然而事后，你其实并没有。你实际上并没有感到正义凛然，你实际上并没有感觉好一些，有时我们实际上对自己的感觉更糟糕了。这与另一个人毫无关系。这完全与我们自己有关。心理学中有一个概念叫做情感预测（affective forecasting）。本质上，这是人类的一种倾向，即错误地预测未来事件会让我们产生什么感觉。在当时，我们认为复仇会让
every fantasy that we have of getting even, our brain strengthens the association between pain and vengeance as the only solution. Here's also what's strange about revenge. Sometimes we do get exactly what we want it. You know, the apology never came, so we did get even. They felt the sting. The balance in theory was restored. And yet afterwards, you don't actually. You don't actually feel righteous, you don't actually feel better, sometimes we actually feel worse about ourselves. This has nothing to do with the other person. It has everything to do with us. There is this idea and psychology of effective forecasting. Essentially, it's our human tendency to mispredict or falsely predict how future events will make us feel. In the moment, we think that revenge is going to make
一切感觉都更好，正义将得到伸张，一切都会感觉很棒。我们认为它能抵消我们的伤害，但我们高估了情感回报，而低估了我们实际会有多糟糕的感觉。特别是，当我们根据复仇的愿望采取行动时，它实际上改变了我们对自己的看法。在那次报复的瞬间，你不再仅仅是这种情况下面对不公的人。你也成了那个对别人做错了事的人。这种道德失调（moral dissonance）让人感到非常不舒服。
everything feel better, the justice will be restored, everything's going to feel great. We think it will cancel out our hurt, but we overestimate the emotional payoff and we underestimate how terrible we're actually going to feel. In particular, when we act on our desire for revenge, it actually changes how we perceive ourselves. In that instance of payback, you are no longer just the person who was wronged in this situation. You also become the person who has wronged someone else. And that moral dissonance is really uncomfortable.
因为它模糊了受害者和施害者之间的界限。它分裂了我们。这就是被这样描述的。它将你分裂成承受痛苦之星前的那个你（受害者），以及为了回应痛苦而变成的那个你——不一定是恶人，但也未必是受害者。普林斯顿大学（Princeton）的神经科学家兼实验心理学家莫莉·克罗克特（Molly Crockett）已经表明，这种道德决策，比如我是否寻求复仇，之所以感觉良好，是因为它激活了奖励网络。它还激活了
because it blurs the boundary between victim and perpetrator. It splits us. That's how this is described. It splits you between the person you were before the pain, the victim, and the person who you became in response to it, not necessarily the villain, but not necessarily the victim either. This neuroscientist and experimental psychologist Molly Crockett at Princeton, she has shown that this kind of moral decision making, such as do I, seek revenge or not, feels good because it activates the reward network. It also activates the
因为它模糊了受害者和加害者之间的界限。它分裂了我们。它是这样被描述的。它将你分成了两半：一半是你遭受痛苦之前的那个你，即受害者；另一半是你为了应对痛苦而变成的那个人，虽然不一定是恶棍，但也未必再是受害者了。普林斯顿大学的神经科学家兼实验心理学家莫莉·克罗克特已经证明，这种道德决策，比如我是否要寻求复仇，之所以会感觉良好，是因为它激活了奖赏回路。它还激活了
empathy network, especially this area called the ventromedial prefrontal cortex, that almost immediately makes you see someone else's pain and feel it yourself, even if you don't like them. Every single person has the structure of their brain, whether it's as active as someone else's or not, but, you know, when you retaliate, those empathy circuits, they don't switch off. They keep processing the other person's pain. And the human brain really struggles to feel pleasure and pain at the same time, to feel empathy and pleasure at the same time. So you have this, like, really uneasy, like, juxtaposition of satisfaction and whether
共情网络，尤其是被称为腹内侧前额叶皮层的这个区域，几乎能立刻让你看到别人的痛苦并自己感同身受，即使你并不喜欢他们。每个人都有这种大脑结构，不管它是不是和别人的大脑一样活跃，但是，你知道，当你进行报复时，那些共情回路并没有关闭。它们一直在处理别人的痛苦。人类的大脑真的很难同时感受到快乐和痛苦，很难同时感受到共情和快乐。所以你会有一种极其不安的感觉，就像是满足感和无论
you acknowledge it or not, a sense of sadness. This is part of why people often describe revenge as like leaving a bad taste. A bunch of social psychologists, one in particular called Rosen Haidt. They have written about the different domains of disgust and how, yes, you feel disgust at like, oh, this food is off, oh, like this smells bad. You also feel moral disgust. moral disgust at having gone down to someone else's level, feeling kind of dirty because of it. That's why when people say things like, I just, I can't understand how they could hurt me, can't understand how they could treat me like this, that's actually a really good thing.
你是否承认它，都会有一种悲伤感。这也是人们经常把复仇描述为留下难以下咽的坏味道的部分原因。一群社会心理学家，其中有一位特别著名，叫罗森·海特。他们写过关于厌恶的不同领域的文章，是的，你会对以下事情感到厌恶：哦，这食物变质了，哦，这闻起来很难闻。你也会感到道德上的厌恶。道德上的厌恶，因为你降到了别人的水平，为此感到有点肮脏。这就是为什么当人们说诸如“我只是不明白他们怎么能伤害我，不明白他们怎么能这样对我”之类的话时，这其实是一件非常好的事。
Of course you can't understand why they did that to you because you're not like them at all. That's a really great thing. of course you can't empathize or try and recreate the situation that made them hurt you because you're not them, you're better than them in this situation. Like, it feels weird to say that, but you are. So should we ever take the low road over the high road? Is it ever acceptable morally to do unto others what they've done to us? Human morality has wrestled with this question for literally, like, for thousands of years.
当然，你无法理解他们为什么要那样对你，因为你和他们完全不同。这真的是一件非常了不起的事。当然，你不能共情，也不能试着去重现让他们伤害你的情境，因为你不是他们，在这种情况下，你比他们更好。听起来说这话有点奇怪，但你确实如此。那么，我们是否应该选择低谷而不是高地？在道德上，以其人之道还治其人之身是否永远是可以接受的？人类的道德在几千年里一直在与这个问题作斗争。
So there's not really anything new I can bring to this conversation other than just summarize the two kind of arguments. On one hand, there's that very ancient law of retaliation. You know, it's famously captured in the Old Testament, life for life, eye for eye, tooth for tooth. In its original context, this wasn't actually meant to encourage. revenge, it was actually meant to discourage cruelty. It didn't say, you know, don't seek revenge. It was basically trying to say, like, there are boundaries around vengeance. It needs to be proportional. You can't kill someone because they stole your cow. You can't, you know, burn their house down because they knocked over your, like, carrot stand. I don't know what my analogies are,
所以，除了总结这两种论点之外，我真的带不了什么新东西给这个对话。一方面，存在着非常古老的报复法。你知道，它在《旧约》中有着著名的表述：以命偿命，以眼还眼，以牙还牙。在其最初的语境中，这实际上并不是为了鼓励复仇，而是为了阻止残忍。它并没有说，你知道，不要寻求复仇。它基本上是想表达，复仇是有界限的。它必须是成比例的。你不能因为别人偷了你的牛就杀了他们，你不能因为别人推翻了你的胡萝卜摊就烧了他们的房子。我不知道我的类比是什么，
but you know what I mean. In its early form, yeah, revenge was totally normalized, but justice in this early sense, it meant balance, it didn't mean escalation. However, as human ethics have evolved, so does our understanding of justice. More than like two millennia later, Martin Luther King Jr., he reframed that same principle when he said, the old law of eye for an eye, tooth through tooth, leaves everyone blind and toothless, right? And his point was that vengeance multiplies suffering. It doesn't actually restore harmony. It corrods it. So what's changed and how we think about doing on to others? Well, modern psychology really suggests that revenge just exists because there is a tension between two competing moral systems. We are taught that we need to seek justice. I feel like that words come up a lot. We're also taught to care about other people.
但你知道我的意思。在其早期形式中，是的，复仇是完全被正常化的，但这种早期意义上的正义意味着平衡，并不意味着升级。然而，随着人类伦理的发展，我们对正义的理解也在发展。两千多年后，马丁·路德·金重新诠释了同样的原则，他说：“以眼还眼、以牙还牙的旧法则让每个人都瞎了眼、成了无牙之人，对吧？”他的观点是，复仇会使苦难倍增。它实际上并不能恢复和谐。它会侵蚀和谐。那么，是什么改变了我们对以其人之道还治其人之身的看法？嗯，现代心理学确实表明，复仇的存在只是因为两个相互竞争的道德体系之间存在张力。我们被教导我们需要寻求正义。我觉得这个词经常出现。我们也被教导要去关心别人。
Care says we should forgive. Justice says they should get what they deserve. That is also why revenge feels so kind of delicious at times. because that moral friction is interesting and doesn't have a right answer. So it's fascinating. We go back and forth and back and forth. We don't really know which one we should do because both feel equally important. Some philosophers, for example, Emmanuel Kant, have argued that justice does actually require retribution and to maintain a moral society. We need to do that. But Canada is like a lot more humanist. traditions do say that it doesn't produce good. Like the highest moral act isn't to mirror someone else's behavior, it is to rise above it. Researchers who specifically study empathy and moral reasoning, they describe this as moral elevation. You will feel better when you witness or encourage or perform forgiveness. So if you are, you know, something to just terrible has happened to you and you want to get revenge and you want to get revenge because you think it will make you feel better, you might not like to hear it, but you will experience
关怀说我们应该原谅。正义说他们应该得到他们应得的。这也是为什么复仇有时会让人感到如此美妙，因为这种道德摩擦很有趣，而且没有标准答案。所以这很迷人。我们来回反复，来回反复。我们真的不知道我们应该做哪一个，因为两者感觉都同样重要。一些哲学家，例如伊曼纽尔·康德，认为正义确实需要报应，为了维护一个道德社会。我们需要这样做。但像卡耐基这样更具人文主义传统的说法是，它并不会产生好的结果。最高的道德行为不是去模仿别人的行为，而是超越它。专门研究共情和道德推理的研究人员将其描述为道德升华。当你见证、鼓励或表现出宽恕时，你会感觉更好。所以，如果你经历了极其糟糕的事情，你想复仇，而且你想复仇是因为你认为这会让你感觉更好，你可能不愿意听到这个，但你会体验到
more reward from not necessarily forgiving somebody, but trying to maybe understand why they did it, trying to maybe not justify it, but just trying to make peace with it without them being involved at all. Forgiveness actually gives us neurologically a deeper sense and kind of reward and sense of dignity and sense of empowerment. Doesn't mean that forgiveness is easy. Doesn't mean that it's even possible. Sometimes choosing not to retaliate isn't about moral superiority.
更多的回报不一定来自于原谅某人，而是来自于试图理解他们为什么这样做，可能不是去为之辩护，而只是试图与之和解，而不需要他们的参与。宽恕实际上在神经学上赋予了我们更深层次的意义、回报感、尊严感和赋权感。这并不意味着宽恕是容易的。这并不意味着这甚至是可能的。有时候选择不报复并不是关于道德优越感，
It's just about refusing to hand over more of your peace and power to a person who already took more of it than they deserve. So maybe the real moral question we're getting to here is whether revenge is acceptable, but whether it is useful for you? If we think about more productive options, radical empathy is like one that's probably going to come up a lot. Radical empathy is like the unconditional empathy and forgiveness that we have for other people's actions. Doesn't mean permitting them, doesn't mean letting them do it again, doesn't mean forgetting. It's just a piece that we restore within ourselves that, you know, we're not, we're going to release the pain that we feel about this. We're going to have empathy for them. It's about actually
而只是拒绝把更多的平静和力量交还给一个已经夺走比应得更多东西的人。所以也许我们在这里探讨的真正的道德问题不是复仇是否可以接受，而是它对你是否有用？如果我们考虑更有成效的选择，激进的同理心可能是经常会被提及的一个。激进的同理心是我们对他人行为的无条件同理心和宽恕。这并不意味着纵容他们，不意味着让他们再次这样做，不意味着遗忘。这只是我们在内心恢复的一种平静，你知道，我们不会，我们要释放我们对这件事感到的痛苦。我们要对他们产生同理心。它是关于实际
really acknowledging like how someone else may have been hurt into their hurt, may have been harmed into harming, may have been driven to cruelty through ignorance or fear. And it is, without a doubt, I think personally, a much more freeing approach. We have seen it again with studies and with neuroimaging, like people who have this radical empathy approach are actually happier. Isn't that like the best revenge? Isn't success and happiness and peace? The best revenge of all? Probably. So maybe it's uncomfortable to hear that that might be the way to go about it. I think that this approach personally is one that it is one that I've adopted in the last year and it has made me just feel a little bit less mad about the world.
真正地认识到别人是如何在他们的痛苦中受过伤的，是如何在受害中加害于人的，是如何被无知或恐惧驱使走向残忍的。毫无疑问，就我个人而言，这是一种更具解放感的方法。我们已经在研究和神经成像中再次看到了这一点，拥有这种激进同理心方法的实际上更快乐。这难道不是最好的复仇吗？成功、快乐和内心的平静难道不是最好的复仇吗？可能吧。所以听到这可能是解决问题的方法，可能会让人觉得不舒服。我认为这种方法就我个人而言是我在过去一年里采用的方法，它让我对这个世界没那么生气了。
You know, I got into such a rut this year, thinking about the world as just like full of terrible people who rule our lives and do terrible things that we just have to watch and observe and that people are cruel and everybody is mad and angry all the time. It wasn't a nice place to be, but I started doing this exercise where when I felt this way, I had to think about someone who I was angered by or mad at that I was going to forgive and I was going to think positive things about. Someone in my life, in that day, in this month, that I really wanted to be angry towards who I could just in that moment symbolically forgive
你知道，今年我陷入了一种窠臼，把世界看作是充满了统治我们生活并做可怕事情的糟糕人类，我们只能看着、观察着，人们很残酷，所有人总是疯狂而愤怒。那不是一个好地方，但我开始做一个练习，每当我这种感觉时，我都必须去想一个让我生气或让我抓狂的人，我要原谅他，我要去想积极的事情。我生活中的某个人，在那一天，在这个月里，我真的很想对他发火，但我可以在那一刻象征性地原谅他
and wish well. And that wasn't for them, even though, of course, in some ways it was. It was for me. People doing bad, hurtful things will have us believe that there is no good in the world, but how can that be true if we demonstrate good and if we choose love? So it actually does, I think, change how you just view the balance of good and evil in a way that's always going to mean that, I don't know, it's always going to mean that you have a more positive outlook. Obviously, not everyone deserves empathy, but this again is not about these people. This is about you. This is about you being able to be free of whatever a pain this person has caused you in one possible way. I think it's just like weird experience
并祝他一切顺利。那不是为了他们，尽管在某些方面当然也是。那是为了我自己。做坏事、伤人的人会让我们相信世界上没有善良，但如果我们展现善良并且选择爱，这怎么可能是真的呢？所以我认为，它确实改变了你对善恶平衡的看法，这种看法总是意味着，我不知道，它总是意味着你会有更积极的人生观。显然，不是每个人都值得同理心，但这再次与这些人无关。这是关于你自己的。这是关于你能以一种可能的方式摆脱这个人带给你的任何痛苦。我认为这只是一种奇怪的体验，
that you have, which is that when you stop needing someone else to suffer in order to feel okay, like you actually really start to move on, which is again annoying and it's frustrating. I love like this idea again of like success is the best revenge or like karma will take care of it for you. I truly believe that. And the interesting thing is that like obviously I love this. science and I love the psychology. I don't have any scientific research or scientific backing to prove that karma will take care of it for me. But anecdotally, I just feel like everything kind of evens out eventually. And it just stops you from having to labor over how you're going to get them back. It just stops you from giving them more of your energy. Like, they've already done something bad to
你所拥有的，就是当你不再需要别人受苦来让自己感觉良好时，就像你真的开始向前迈进一样，这同样是烦人和沮丧的。我再次喜欢这种想法，比如成功是最好的复仇，或者因果报应会为你照顾好它。我真的相信这一点。有趣的是，虽然我很喜欢科学，我也喜欢心理学，但我没有任何科学研究或科学支持来证明因果报应会为我照顾好这一切。但根据经验，我只是觉得一切最终都会趋于平缓。它只是让你不必费心去想你要怎么报复他们。它只是阻止了你把更多的精力分给他们。就像，他们已经对你做了一件坏事，
you. That's bad enough. Don't let them then take all these precious moments that you could be spending, giving love to others or doing other things. Obviously, easier said than done. I feel like everything we talked about today is easier said than done. But I do think that it's the more peaceful approach. And I do think that like having had like real grudges like about people in the past and at times like not being able to let it go for many, many years. The best thing that I've done is to just like seriously and vigorously and aggressively and aggressively focus on myself and to just put everything into being successful, everything into being a good person so that like on the off chance they come to check in on me or they start watching or
这已经够糟糕了。不要让他们再拿走所有这些你可以用来给其他人以爱或做其他事情的宝贵时光。显然，说起来容易做起来难。我觉得我们今天谈论的一切都是说起来容易做起来难。但我确实认为这是更平静的方法。我确实认为，过去曾经对别人怀有真正的怨恨，有时甚至很多年都无法释怀。我做过的最好的事情就是认真、强力、积极且极具攻击性地专注于我自己，把一切都投入到成功中，一切都投入到成为一个好人中，这样万一他们来查看我的近况或者他们开始关注或者
whatever it is or, you know, they follow me on Instagram like, I don't know. on the off chance they try and slide back in like they can just see that they tried their best to like kind of bring me down and it like never worked and the thing is is that it actually doesn't matter whether they ever do notice that I'm happy or do notice that I'm successful or do notice that my life is good because when I started focusing on that stuff I just stopped caring about them completely and it was like incredibly incredibly liberating and it was just like so much better than any form of retaliation. I feel like I've done both, but silence and just like silence, no contact, completely focusing on my own lane, was the most empowering thing that I
无论是什么，或者，你知道，他们在 Instagram 上关注我，我不知道。万一他们试图溜回来，他们就能看到他们已经尽力把我拉下来，但却从来没有成功过。问题是，他们是否注意到我很成功，或者注意到我的生活很好，其实根本不重要，因为当我开始专注于这些事情时，我完全不再关心他们了，这真是难以置信的解放，比任何形式的报复都要好得多。我觉得我都经历过，但是保持沉默，就像沉默、不联系、完全专注于自己的道路，是我能做到的最有力量的事。这就是我对复仇的思考。这就是复仇的心理学，以及我们为什么寻求它，为什么想要它，它是否真的值得。还有激进的同理心、成功是最好的复仇、卡玛式的回应，这其实也是一种接纳疗法，接纳你无法控制别人，但你可以控制自己的反应。这才是它真正强大赋能的地方。我一直在滔滔不绝地谈论这个，因为我觉得我现在已经把它深深地印在你们脑海里了。但我希望你们喜欢这一集。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在下方留下一个橄榄表情符号，来象征橄榄枝，象征宽恕，不一定是那种你需要向任何人伸出的橄榄枝，
could do. So those are my musings on revenge. That is the psychology of revenge and why we seek it, why we want it, whether it's actually worthwhile. And there's like radical empathy, success is the best revenge, carmatic kind of response to it that it's kind of a form of like acceptance therapy as well, accepting that you can't control other people, but you can control your response. Like, that's really what's empowering about it. I'm going on and on about this because I feel like I've drilled it into you by now. But I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you have made it this far, I want you to leave a little olive emoji down below to like symbolize an olive branch, symbolize forgiveness, not necessarily the olive branch that you need to extend to anybody,
而只是我们为自己请求的象征，原谅我们自己，在心中原谅别人，而不是通过行动，并且能够在不寻求复仇的情况下继续前进。我要感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本集的贡献。我也要感谢大家的收听。这一集实际上是在 YouTube 上发布的。所以这不是我经常谈论的事情。但是，是的，如果你想去重温它，我们现在有 YouTube 节目了。可能不会。但如果你想观看像这样其他节目，你可以去 YouTube 搜索 The Psychology of
but like just the symbol of what we're asking for for ourselves, forgiving ourselves, forgiving somebody else in our mind, not through actions, and just being able to move forward without seeking revenge. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. And I want to thank you guys for listening. This episode was actually on YouTube. So it's not something I've talked about a lot. But, Yeah, we now do YouTube episodes if you want to go and I guess rewatch it. Probably not. But if you want to watch other episodes like this one, you can go to YouTube at The Psychology of
your 20s。如果你想要这集的文字稿，你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我们。它是免费的。我会在描述中留下链接。如果你想看幕后花絮、节目解析、我们对明年的计划，或者只是想与播客保持联系，也可以在 Instagram 上关注我们。这是找到我们的最佳地点。但话虽如此，这一切都结束了，我将以这句话来结束本集：再次感谢您的收听。直到下一次，保重，善良，温柔对待
your 20s. You can also subscribe to us on Substack if you would like the transcript of this episode. It's free. I'll leave a link in the description. And also follow us on Instagram if you want to see behind the scenes or an episode breakdown or what we're planning for the next year or just want to keep in touch with the podcast. us at the best place to find us. But with all that said, with all that done, I'm going to close the episode by saying, thank you again for listening. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to
你自己。不要总是去寻求复仇。它可能不像你想象的那样令人满意。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员
yourself. Don't always go after revenge. It might not be as satisfying as you think. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题
and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world
都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方上的 TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在...
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the...
《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析其经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过它的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。澄清一下，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但是，是的，是的，真的。但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。
the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听 Look Back At It。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so much. many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit
特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求
of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我卡尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
打开你免费的 I Heart Radio 应用程序。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法院听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的寻找真相的法庭之战。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，对吧？我作假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped Podcast，
or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
或者无论你在哪里获取播客。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人卡尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或任何您获取播客的地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我作假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是 Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方上的 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何您获取播客的地方收听 The Girlfriends, Trust Me, Babe。这是一个 IHeart 播客，保证由人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。